[Musique]
et oui le jeu de la taupe sachez que il
ya une personne ici qui a été victime
qui a été victime d'un terrible accident
toi royaume à cette victime va pas se
mentir je vous le dis elle est autour de
la table c'est cboe jean-michel exact
vous avez été agressé par une personne
de l'équipe grille mais oui ici autour
de la table on va voir tout de suite ce
qui s'est passé regardez
oh
tour de mes deux là
[Musique]
sachez que la sont la chauffer lol et
qui vous aller enquêter également chez
vous et olivier marchal viendra enquêter
avec nous avait dit dans un instant bien
entendu ma c'est normal on va passer au
jeu d'actu c'est le jeu de l'atome c'est
parti ce plateau
[Musique]
j'ai envie vous étiez dans la rue proche
de chez vous tout à l'heure vous avez
été agressée olivier marchal et mes
cailloux devons mener des enquêtes
vous allez devoir trouver qui a agressé
jean michel maire ce qu'on voulait
revoir la scène
oui moi j'ai vu un indice déjà la wii
j'ai vu un indice en parce que j'ai
regardé les images en coulisse parce que
je travaille en de faire votre émission
regarde
oh
tour de mes deux là
une personne ici tout est inclus voilà
je vous le dis qui a commis son larcin
sinueux être commissaire marshall
commissaire marshall commissaire ue
alors je vous le dit jean mi si vous
répondez aux questions d'actu avant les
autres se posent des questions à tout le
monde les questions d'actu sur la télé
oui gagnant un indice pour peut être
trouver la taupe d'accord si vous
trouvez la taupe à la fin avec le
concours d'olivier marchal et demie
cailloux ou partir à marrakech mais
rendons la plupart déjà et l'alsace
sinon la tow partir à la raquette
d'accord perso nous on a rien compris à
tout ça mais alors en fait fabuleux roux
garou or il est là même jeu sauf qu'il
s'appelle la tossée passe pas tout à
fait pareil quel animateur va reprendre
les rênes de la nouvelle version de
bonnes émissions cultes la carte aux
trésors oui cyril féraud
ouais c'est cyril féraud abattoirs de
réanimateurs d'ailleurs d'avoir encore
une autre émission
au départ ce n'était pas prévu il
voulait un jeu d'aventuré mais
totalement originales créations une
sorte de des racines et des ailes qui
change
et finalement la carte aux trésors
coûtait trop cher fallait débloquer 1
million d'euros pour développer juste le
format away et puis où je pense qu'ils
ont mis la main à la poche
et puis l'émission sera tournée au
printemps j'ai mis la main à la poche
oui d'accord oui ça montre qu'ils sont
complètement à la dérive
il avait annulé l'émission parce qu'elle
marchait plus et là et la relance avec
delphine ernotte c'est la catastrophe
france télévisions 2 3 4 5 elle va tous
nous ruiner le sauver de quoi et de coût
pour mille et je suis téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
quand même bizarre de relancer une
émission qui avait fait son temps qu'il
y avait arrêtée faute d'audience mais
qui coûte très cher pourquoi relancer
une machine machine heroes à l'exil dont
la normale c'est qu'on le met à toutes
les sauces
c'est qu'on va cramer l'époque savoir où
on va voir à noël pour l'instant ça va
et cd
voilà c'est des formats différents je
pense que ça va aller qui que va
prochainement sortir
christian quesada l'ancien champion des
12 coups de midi et ça c'est important
qu'un petit par les mamans c'est un peu
vulgaire face à un des noms un livre oui
un roman il a décidé de raconter son
histoire vous savez qu'il est parti de
rien il a gagné 800 9000 auront un jeu
et sa vie a changé
christian quesada vraiment c'est vrai
séisme ça pourrait être un film jean
michel maire pour l'instant n'avait
répondu à aucune question
mais nous dit qu'on n'a pas lundi bah
non c'est que c'est que pour aller chez
elle facilement michel répond pour
l'instant jean michel est un petit peu
endormi mais il répondra bientôt
je vous rappelle qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
vous agressez j'achète lâchement on
connaît la personne et sur ce plateau
révèle sur ses pas un chroniqueur qui
vient que lundi à bahreïn pas parce que
c'est roger dans un instant regarder ce
qui vous attend on se retrouve dans un
affront fait éliminer déjà quatre
personnes bones et poids ouais alors
j'ai me geraldine ouais bah pierre ouais
valérie et isabelle d'accord
titoff qu'il a pu le il a pu
physiquement dimanche olivier arrivait
normalement vous avez le faire venir le
faire vous retrouver tu as fait ça vous
allez interroger chaque heure chaque
chroniqueur qui restent blancs dans ce
qu'ils ont fait ça s'est passé à quelle
heure je pense que ça obligeait
d'après-midi milieu de prix parce que
c'est parce que jean michel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si jamais certains qu il a le don
d'ubiquité
alors ils firent est ok donc il reste
maxime guény kelly titoff et gilles
verdez et benjamin castaldi
olivier et michael nous à les interroger
un par un ses passes à quelle heure en
milieu d'après-midi vers 5h donc ils
vont on va voir si l'on a un alibi
si où il était on peut commencer par
titoff chez vous faire chez vous essayez
de trouver la taupe si vous la trouvez
aux parts à marrakech également est-ce
qu'on peut revoir le film par contre
vous voulez le vôtre oui ça dure une
heure et demie on va leur prêt à écouter
on annule émission ce soir c'est carbone
sur ses murs c'est gratuit c'est cadeau
merci
[Applaudissements]
là
jean tigana le régicide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pl la styliste bande dessinée mal comme
[Applaudissements]
la démocratie des biens j'ai même pas
fini bonsoir monsieur olivier nous vous
voulez revoir le dollar un dollar
oh
tour de mes deux là
est ce qu'on peut mais alors olivier et
mickaël est chez vous vous également je
pense qu'il s'agit d'un individu de type
féminin non c'est vrai pourquoi remet
dans la façon de sautiller de la façon
de jeter le saut il ya des trémies nos
féminines goût auquel il avait mis des
villes qui un peu féminin est entre le
marteau et l'enclume
non peut-être qu'on pourrait faire
passer un casting de petits sauts en
l'air olivier olivier il élimine donc
toutes les femmes et la lumière enfin
comme tous les ans rené on élimine
benjamin jean teuf et gilles et maxime
non on le garde
basescu maxime on le garde aujourd'hui
les menus mais on le sent taciturne sait
pas utiliser sans vie et plus agile que
les deux autres il est espiègle
alors attention il reste donc y sont
fournis avec des patins reste un label y
reste
kelly y restent énormes maxime
mais les autres ont tous été éliminés
réveillez vous ils ont enlevé tout le
monde là il enlevait toulouse thierry
rey skalli maxime et isabel benjamin est
un vieux d'hôtes à éliminer il s'appelle
est dans une mauvaise connexion wifi en
vue la vie djellaba laquelle le pied le
piège se dire à des images dénudées et
oui alors il reste plus que kanye maxi
maxi cie vous avez le sens où les deux
castings de sault casting dessous
j'avais un vieux doute quand même sur
balles jamal se fait quand la taupe est
parti mais allégé fumée derrière c'est
un ouvrage à main se vendent toujours de
7 à tulle ans je me bats alors d'abord
ils vont vous donner leur avis et c'est
vous qui choisirent après on est passé
par là ils peuvent faire semblant de ne
pas savoir ce sujet on est là sur l'asie
par la wii à l'italie 1 2 3 merci que
l'on évoqué les progrès peut-être les
chocolats chez les sous sols allez donc
ça tu te la raconter
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a simulé
[Applaudissements]
olivier et michael à votre avis qui
était la taupe est hélas peut savoir où
est ce que vous étiez aujourd'hui à 15
heures jeudi j'ai déterré la thur 17
heures master pas été juste à côté
je préparais l'émission voilée on a été
le fourbe
c'est vrai ou les écrits moi je dirais
crédit parce que j'aimerais bien
interroger en tête à tête et qui dit où
est ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui cerné
boissieu
je voulais interroger qu'il y aurait 7 à
c'est vrai olivier voulait poser une
dernière question qu'elle était numéro
de portable voilà la magie ou de laisser
le 06 je pense je pense c'est maxime max
maxime vous dites pas que moi je dirais
qu'il est maudite kelly alors est ce que
vous écoutez vous jean michel vous
pensez à qui le dos maximum maxime est
ce que vous écoutez olivier marchal
ancien flic ancien flic ou est ce que
vous écoutez michaël youn anciens qu'on
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
trucs aux téléspectateurs ouais
en tout cas les deux sont très forts
parce que la taupe est une des deux
qu'une des deux essais une taupe
oui non indiana toronto est une des
mails à des tops sont masculines alors
jean-michel à ils ont été très bons ils
ont été très bien où tu es mikel ou
arriver j'aurais plutôt tendance à
croire michael parce qu'il sait pas le
saut ça m'a vraiment vous voyez tout
maxime serait plutôt maximy maxime
maxime kenny regarder
[Applaudissements]
excellent il faut toujours croire la
police nationale impressionné je suis
sûr que vous aussi chez vous c'est un
précieux quand même c'est peut-être
aussi même si vous voulez dîner au resto
avec elle aussi non non ça rien à voir
ils vont être que tu a simulé tons
chauds et ça aurait dû donner à des
olives et quand ils sont et comment vous
l'avez vous avez senti qu'il y ait droit
au petit oui mais je suis arrivé la
taupe avait laissé avec la santé la
taupe sa santé a présenté la tonnelle
n'a pas été trouvé rien donc kelly phare
à marrakech
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon costume d'iznogoud vous pouvez
partir avec nous belle part mais qui
avec toute cette équipe
oh merde
[Applaudissements]